hey youtubers is charlie thank you
everyone that left questions on my
episode 5 video I know everyone had a
lot of questions about grayscale ancient
Valyria and we know what might be
happening like the big WTS later this
season so I tried to add all those
questions so here we go careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen the episode
yet first question Joseph asks the stone
man did touch Tyrion and he seems to be
immune does this confirm that he might
be a secret Targ no i think that the
show just didn't want to give him
grayscale if they wanted him to have
gray scale they probably would have
given him that Jorah Mormont moment it
doesn't mean Tyrians completely safe but
he's probably safe for now next question
Jason asks do you think that Theon reek
will tell Santa the truth about her
brothers and if he does do you think
that she would believe him oh you mean
like you know the fact that he didn't
really kill her brothers no I think
she'll find out though there are
probably people in and around Winterfell
that know that her brothers are still
alive but right now I feel like the show
has tried to make Sansa as uncomfortable
as possible if she were to find out her
brothers were alive that would be a big
source of comfort I don't think the show
wants to give that to her yet no matter
how stone-cold she seemed in this
episode things are probably going to get
worse for her before they get better
next question adam asks can you explain
the gray skin disease so you're talking
about gray scale i think of it the way i
think of it is like a form of leprosy
that's just really contagious gilly did
a really good job of explaining its
effects its prolonged effects so you
should just rewatch that scene to your
skin and soft tissues slowly hard until
it looks like you have scales like you
know stony skin that's what they call
him the stone men eventually your body
just shuts down Gilly says that her
sisters went mad too but the madness
could be just side effects from having a
prolonged disease like that and being
left to die out in the cold like if you
had a debilitating disease no matter
what it might do to your body your mind
might be fine but if you are left out in
the cold to die I mean you probably a
little nuts to as where does the
Stoneman that we saw in this episode
seemed I think that they were just super
desperate next question Youssef asks do
you think that Stannis and his army will
be facing the White Walkers before they
reach Winterfell no I think all the
White Walkers that we see will be north
of the wall up at hardhome winters
pretty much here I mean I feel like on
the show they're going to have a moment
where they say winter is here just
because winter is coming in such a big
saying it
like a really cliche slam dunk to give a
character winter has come and then you
know Q like scary inception music like
at the end of this episode so Stannis
isn't just gonna like march down there
unscathed next question Cristiano asks
do you think that the dragon feeding
scene was the most disturbing one that
Sophie talked about or something even
more gruesome up north coming oh so
you're talking about yeah like sophie
Turner was talking about a really
gruesome moment yet no i think her
moment will be something specific to her
storyline there were a number of vectors
like The Onion Knight for instance in
real life the actor said that there's
going to be some really gruesome moment
happening because his story takes place
you know within Stannis's camp you know
around those characters I think his
moment that he was talking about is
specific to that so whatever sophie
Turner was talking about is something
that'll be specific to Ramsey reek in
Santa probably you know maybe fat wall
duh maybe Roose Bolton to you have to
remember that a lot of the actors don't
film together so like if an actor films
on the other side of the world they
don't know what's going on in the rest
of the episodes like they haven't seen
the whole season usually when an actor
gets script pages is just for the scenes
they're doing that day or that week so
like they they don't have script pages
for what's going on in an episode that
they're not being filmed for next
question in Sakura asks I was wondering
why tanaris still leaves the other two
dragons wriggle on Vissarion locked and
chained up in the dungeon well that's
just appease the people she locked them
up because drogue on 8 that peasant boy
if drogon had been around at the time
she would have locked him up to she may
have felt like at the time she was
unable to control them but but I think
that she's slowly coming around on that
really though the biggest reason they're
still in there is just because she wants
to keep everyone happy which clearly as
we can see from the sons of the harpy
isn't working at all next question Rubin
asks episode 9 was real to be called the
dance of the Dragons as it is in episode
9 what do you think will happen well I
can't confirm that that's the title of
the episode if that's the case and it's
like a typical episode 9 WTF there will
probably be metaphorical dragons dancing
is in like people like Targaryen and
literal dragons dancing is in like
dragons flying around that's just
speculation I couldn't find any
confirmation about the title of the
episode you know remember episodes like
kill the boy have metaphorical and
literal meanings I think the
metaphorical interpretation of the title
is actually more interesting if they're
talking about dancing
darienne's like Targaryen characters we
have to consider is the show going to
offer us more evidence that there is a
secret Targaryen on the show next
question panic res asks this season
seems to be building up for a big moment
with shireen what do you think is going
to happen what do you think it's
building up to well you know I think
Stannis's faith is going to be tested by
Melisandre remember the reason that they
took Gendry Melisandre only told Solis
to take Shireen with them after they
lost skendri Remember The Onion Knight
let him go and he wrote off right out of
the story we have no idea where he is he
sailed right off the page so it seems
like Shireen is back up for royal blood
for some reason it seemed like
Melisandre is unable to make a second
shadow baby with Stannis clearly that's
not the direction she would go with
shireen she would probably try to use
her blood to do something that we
haven't seen before hopefully you know
maybe that will be a WTF moment I'm a
really big fan of Shireen in the show is
doing that on purpose like they had that
moment with Stannis because they want
you to really like Stannis think like
he's a really good guy they want you to
really love Shireen because she's
totally adorable so what have we learned
about Game of Thrones in the four
seasons you know four and a half seasons
we've been watching it the minute you
love someone a lot it's just going to
yank the rug right out from under you so
brace myself winter is coming for
someone next question John asks what is
the doom are you talking about the doom
of Valyria so that's like a cataclysmic
event when the 14 flames all erupted
those are volcanoes in and around the
Valyrian Peninsula think what happened
at Pompeii one volcano exploded and
buried a civilization Valyria had many
many volcanoes that all erupted around
the same time there's a lot of theories
as to why it happened you know the most
practical is is that over the thousand
years of the rise and height of the
Valyrian Empire they just over mind the
area around the volcanoes if you
remember Fellowship of the Ring Gandalf
talked about how the dwarves delved too
deep into the earth till they woke the
Balrog something kind of like that the
Valerians got too greedy mine too deep
destabilize the earth and it calls the
volcanoes to explode there are theories
that you know people that Valyria had
conquered used magic to help make the
volcanoes explode but because of a
confluence of events the volcanoes
exploded and that's what destroyed
buleria the volcanoes
themselves next question Igor asks do
you think that Danny is starting to
behave like the Mad King seriously that
scene reminded me of poor old Rickard
stark yeah you know I choose fire to my
champion roast him alive no I think they
want you to think that they want you to
mentally draw that parallel but I don't
think that she's literally turning into
the Mad King the hope is is that you
know if Tyrion gets there he can give
her good advice and she'll slowly back
off but I do think that there's going to
be a number of WTF moments that will
still happen in and around marine
donairs standing over his daughter you
know it does kind of look like she's a
little mad but I think that she's just
feels very sure in the decision that
she's made thank you so much everyone
for so many questions these are always a
ton of fun to do I mean I'm expecting
some more changes from the books but
some really great WTF moment so i'll try
to explain what the changes are whenever
we see min episodes congratulations to
the book giveaway winners nixa and
Gabriel Benitez you guys win your choice
of feast for crows or Dance with Dragons
both hardbacks signed by george RR
martin whoever DMV first could just
choose which book they want and the
other one will get the other book so DM
me so we can find a way to ship the
books out to you guys next week's
giveaway will be back to the HBO now
subscriptions if there's any special
bonus videos you guys want a request
just let me know in the comments episode
6 video next week be sure to subscribe
to get it the title of that episode is
unbent unbowed unbroken the motto of
house Martell so probably gonna be some
really exciting door and stuff going on
just in case you guys haven't seen it
you can click here for my episode 5
video from last night and you can click
here to learn all about Liana stark
thank you so much watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tomorrow
you